so ladies and gentlemen thanks so much
for coming to what's the second in our
harriman institute sponsored series of
lectures on human rights strategies and
measuring human rights outcomes one of
the things that we're doing with the
series is we're having experts talk
about theories of change for how to
promote human rights what's the theory
of change behind the strategy and then
empirically testing whether or not the
strategy for promoting human rights
actually works so we're although the
Herman Institute is of course the
Institute that studies the
post-communist world Eurasia and a lot
of our interest in the project is
thinking about strategies for promoting
human rights in the post-communist world
strategies that have been tried and how
did they turn out but also what
strategies might be effective in a
post-communist environment is a good bit
of our concern but we're starting off
the series by looking more generally and
comparatively at strategies for
promoting human rights that have been
tried anywhere and everywhere in the
world to evaluate what has worked and
what ought to be on the menu as human
rights promoters attack this agenda in
the post-communist word world now and in
the future so we are fortunate to have
with us tonight Beth Simmons who's a
professor of government at harvard
university who has written a fabulous
book called mobilizing for Human Rights
which has been described by Katherine
sicking who was our speaker last week
and inaugurated this series
professor sick and has described a bet
Simmons book as the most important new
work by a social scientist on
international law and human rights and
in this book of Beth Simmons addresses
what I see as the mainstream approach of
human rights organizations for promoting
human rights in the world namely
starting with the formulation of Human
Rights norms especially embodied in
international treaties and using those
norms to catalyze and mobilize actors in
civil society to push for the
implementation of those norms and so
Beth lays out the logic behind that
strategy of promoting rights and then
she very rigorously and systematically
tests to see whether that strategy works
but also particularly interesting for us
is under what conditions in what kinds
of countries does this particular
approach to promoting Human Rights get
dramatic positive results and also under
what kinds of conditions does this
strategy produce less impressive results
so we want to learn tonight both how and
why this works but also when does this
not work and from the post-soviet
standpoint like what parts of our part
of the globe are conducive for this
strategy and what parts of the
post-communist world might actually
require different strategies to be
effective so Beth Simmons in addition to
this fabulous new book hot off the press
from Princeton University Press is also
the author of an award-winning 1995 book
called who adjusts which is on an
international political economy topic
it won the prize the Woodrow Wilson
award for essentially the best book in
political science for for that year and
she has her PhD from Harvard we have two
distinguished and lively and interesting
discussants to comment on professor
Simmons presentation tonight we have Ken
Roth who's since 1993 the Executive
Director of Human Rights Watch and
before that he was a federal prosecutor
for the iran-contra case and he's a
graduate of yale law school and after
Ken Roth we have our very own Alex
Cooley who's a professor in the
political science department at Barnard
College who's been very busy writing a
despite his tender years a long list of
books on the end of empire state
building the politics of foreign bases
in democratizing countries and a widely
cited article on the strategies of
non-governmental organizations the NGO
scramble and he's a Columbia PhD so with
that I'm going to turn it over to beth's
Simmons and please tell us about
thank you very much for this opportunity
to speak here at the Harriman Center and
I should disclose from the very outset
that I'm not a scholar of the
post-soviet world but I hope that some
of the things that I had to say today at
least spark some ideas as Jack with
suggesting spark some ideas for how to
think about whether in to what extent
international law can has or has the
potential to play a role in some of the
parts of the world that you are most
familiar with honest i'm going to said
i'm going to outline a set of conditions
under which i argue that international
treaties have actually had some impact
on the ground now my question tonight
and some of you who come to the human
rights area would rather have posed the
question what impacts human rights what
influences or improves human rights I
come at this question because I sort of
came in through the door of
international law on to this question
instead i'm looking at a narrower
question what influence has
international law had on human rights
this book that i'm going to be
discussing tonight was originally going
to be a lot broader than what you're
going to hear this evening it was not
going to just be about human rights it
was going to be about international law
compliance generally but for a couple of
reasons I decided to hone in on the
human rights area despite the fact that
you could sort of get the impression
that my background is quite a bit more
in international political economy than
it is in the area of human rights and
there were two reasons why i decided to
hone in on the human rights area and the
first one is the problem that we don't
have a lot of good international
relations theory for thinking about why
states might want to engage this area
why they might want to create treaties
why they might want to create a
legalized regime and what kinds of
influences we could expect that to have
weak theory the second reason I decided
to hone in and this area was to be
completely Frank was that when I tried
to look for research assistants at the
University of California Berkeley when I
was starting to research this area i
would put ads out for undergraduate
to join my research project and I told
them I'm going to do something on trade
a chapter on money a chapter on
territorial disputes and treaties and a
chapter on human rights and out of 40
applications that I would get for these
jobs fully 30 of them wanted to pile on
to the human rights area and so I
decided you know there's a real need for
addressing this issue area and that's
why the book that I'm going to discuss
tonight takes this focus on trying to
understand how the international legal
system has influenced human rights
behavior and the message is going to be
I think appropriate to the theme of the
series that is going to be unfolding
here over the course of the next
semester or so is that international law
has provoked some change in many
countries that ratified treaties in
particular stimulate organization
participation and mobilization when the
following conditions hold when people
live in conditions where they can be
convinced that the right will
drastically change their well-being and
when they live under conditions in which
they have some chance of making a demand
that will succeed and I'm going to
really explain what I mean by this but
the shorthand terms I have in mind is
when there is a motive and a means for
demanding compliance with a ratified
treaty that treaties provide very useful
strategic tools for trying to achieve
your goals in the human rights area now
with the 450 page book yeah so I guess
it raises the question why did it take
so many pages to try to establish this
point I think primarily on that that as
it exists right now there's not a lot of
evidence on this issue area there's not
a lot of systematic look at the sort of
a range of outcomes to see whether
international law really has had much of
an influence of course it's an area
everybody has an opinion on you know
that is people presume or hold priors if
you will about the influence event
national law but the evidence I don't
think has been readily assembled in one
place so part of what I want to do this
evening is to give you a sort of a
little flavor of the kind of evidence
that can be brought to bear in this
issue on this issue as well I have two
distinguished discusses tonight and I I
can never predict what a discussant will
say but I'm going to suggest that there
are sort of two kinds of responses
generally and I would imagine that Ken
Roth will be closer to one and that Alex
will be closer to the other and so one
reaction that I've gotten in terms of
sort of the more practical oriented
community as Beth you are leaning on an
open door of course we use these
treaties it's obvious that we use these
treaties to try to mobilize groups and
to create and stimulate demand sometimes
litigating when that seems like a
reasonable possibility and and so so my
message to those folks is we have a
number of Alex coolies in the audience
that is we have a number of scholars
that come from the direction of
international relations and have a
harder time imagining that the
cumulative effect of these treaties over
time would really amount to anything
very positive on the ground and this is
because all the shortcomings that we
well know of that these treaties are
difficult to enforce internationally
that outside actors States in particular
often have very little motive to become
involved and entangled in the human
rights issue error issues of other
states and that in many cases they would
just rather conduct state relations on a
more diplomatic level rather than
critiquing domestic political practices
so what I want to do tonight is to not
offer you proof of my proposition but
instead just offer evidence of the
proposition that these treaties have
made a difference on the ground to a
broad range of countries I'm going to
specify some conditions under which
these treaties have been especially
important
especially useful and the bottom line
message is not that we should stop doing
everything else but that these treaties
rightfully belong in a toolkit that the
international community should use and
should encourage locals to use as well
when they are trying to articulate the
kinds of demands that they would like to
see their governments meet in the area
of human rights let me start with just a
little bit of background about the book
I mean you know one initial question is
why do we have an international legal
regime for human rights at all and I
think I think this is an interesting
question and it's important I feel like
to put it in a broader context over the
course of the 20th century where a lot
of things are happening a lot of things
are happening that I think build sort of
a context in a background in which these
treaties might eventually gain some kind
of traction so you know if we were to
have had this lecture 60 years ago the
stunning fact is there would be almost
nothing to say that is there be almost
nothing nope no tree used to point to
but a lot of changes that occurred over
the course of the 20th century and they
have given rise I think to the
possibility for the development of a
meaningful regime first democratization
these treaties empower individuals visa
to their governments the natural
constituency for such treaties would be
democratic constituencies would be
countries in which there is a broad
demand and broad responsiveness to the
polity to the individuals and groups in
the polity so the fact that there's been
democratization over the course of the
century has have made it possible to
create an international human rights
regime that might be meaningful the
second development over time is that
their engine in international law quite
generally quite aside from the
development of the human rights regime
there's been a growing tendency that
treaties hold States Parties more and
more accountable over time if you were
to look in the area of arms control if
you were to look in the area of
international
monetary relations the incidence of
reporting mechanisms monitoring
mechanisms and surveillance mechanisms
have increased throughout the
international legal structure maybe it
was prime time sometime mid century to
take into account this stronger demand
for accountability in the international
legal system and of course international
civil society as well the idea that
increasingly the transactions cost for
communication have decreased so
significantly over the course of the
20th century that it's been very
possible for those that that are
represent or are take part in
international civil society to assemble
and disseminate information that ends up
making breaking I should say the
monopoly of states over information
increasingly possible of course the one
of the main things to keep in mind is
that there were proximate conditions as
well these are well known the Second
World War of course gave rise to the
development of an international legal
regime precisely because of the
atrocities of the Nazi regime in
addition though decolonization I think
pushed the movement along for the
development of an international legal
regime so countries that were newly
independent that were pressing for the
recognition of people's rights or groups
rights these have either colonizers made
good allies in this development of the
international human rights regime in the
1940s and 1950s civil rights movements
were important as well so that a lot of
the inspiration for what went one
internationally in the creation of a
universal declaration and an
international covenant for Civil and
Political Rights reflected many national
movements as well and drew mutual
inspiration from domestic developments
so the Alliance for codifying the
principles that were eventually
contained in the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights and putting them into a
binding treaty form I think came down to
a cut to a combination of small
democracies
and newly independent nations who are
interested as well as non-governmental
actors who were interested in creating
legal strictures to control government's
government's behaviors visa vie their
own people what you'll notice is missing
from this coalition are the powerful
countries so the United States of course
was interested in a non-binding
Universal Declaration the British board
especially interested in in legally
binding treaties certainly the Soviet
Union was not for reasons that are
probably obvious as well so it took this
alliance I think to really get the
creation of the international regime off
the ground the results over time was the
development of a large number of
treaties which we can see taking off
between 1945 1950 and then increasing
this is a picture here which sort of
looks in at the cumulative number of
treaties enforce non-binding
declarations enforced relating to the
human rights area and other kinds of
agreements and standards but we can see
increasingly the bottom sort of set of
the brightest darkest part of the
picture there relates to legally binding
multilateral treaties that address the
human rights area so this raises some
interesting questions about why States
once they're sort of faced with this
decision of whether or not to ratify a
treaty or not would really want to put
themselves on the line and publicly
commit themselves to observing one of
these legally binding international
treaties now when I start to examine
this question I decided to start looking
at six of the core treaties the core
human rights treaties basically these
are the ones that I focus on when I try
to look at the question of why do
governments commit themselves I mean
after all wouldn't it be easier to stand
aside not get involved and sort of not
put your reputation on the line or make
a promise that in fact
we'll live up to certain international
standards with respect to human rights
so when I was looking at these six
treaties I was noticing some interesting
patterns over time now most many people
not legal scholars generally that many
international relations scholars will
argue that these treaties are ratified
simply because they're costless they're
not enforced there's no easy way to hold
the state to its obligations and so it's
simply cost listen States take these
sort of symbolic gestures to ratify
these treaties well if that was the case
we faced some puzzles but that's the
case it's hard to understand why you
might get some of these patterns over
time in ratification what I'm showing
you now are the six major treaties and
what I'm doing is stacking up the
ratification basically of those treaties
over time on the vertical axis we're
just getting a total number of
ratifications for these six treaties if
we were to add them all up and there's
some interesting things going on here if
treaties were costless why doesn't
everybody jump on board and why don't
they do it immediately or the same for
all treaties and that's not what's going
on here instead what's going on is we
can see some treaties glean a lot of
international ratifications very quickly
the one that especially does so is the
children's convention the Convention on
the Rights of the Child that's the dark
purple one that's near the top look one
space above that though and you'll see
the torture convention and the torture
convention is the orange one over there
you can see on the very top it's slow
getting off the ground and it never does
get the broad adherence through
ratification that the Convention on the
Rights the child gets and we can think
of a lot of reasons why that might be
detect the case torture is often related
to issues having to do with national
security issues
or sometimes just been the government's
preceding Security Income Security
torturing opponents that type of thing
children on the other hand are seen as
harmless beings and for the most part
don't pose much of a big risk for
ratification in addition there's another
difference between these two three days
as well the torture condition the
torture treaty is non-delegable it does
not admit of exception despite some
creative interpretations that we've
heard over the last eight to ten years
or so it is not the case that there are
any circumstances under which the
torture convention permits a country to
portrait non-durable on the other hand
the children's convention is often
described as an aspirational tree it
does admit that there are some
circumstances under which it would be
difficult for estates to meet its full
obligations and it fully recognizes
those conditions so there are some
differences across these treaties that
we should not be able to see if it were
simply the fact that ratifying these
treaties was completely costless across
the board this pattern is also difficult
to understand if ratifying treaties are
cost us some regions don't engage in
ratification of these treaties on nearly
the same scale as other regions do so
this is just how the average number of
these six trees ratified regionally then
we can see clearly that asia and the
pacific region is a lagging reason
region for some reason it doesn't almost
wat of course we can see that Eastern
Europe and the former Soviet Union the
area of the world that this institution
is particularly interested in is one of
the big rata fires of these treaties but
that does raise the question as to sort
you know if it's costless why aren't you
know the wisent countries in the Asian
region doing it as well if they
same preferences and faced the same
costs we should see the same thing
across these regions and we payton leigh
don't see that well one of the things
that i tried to spell out in this book
is what how do we sort of sort out our
expectations about ratification of these
treaties and I imagine that we could
divide the world into a set of
expectations there are countries out
there which we would expect to comply
for the most part with a tree me because
i already have fairly good ones
practices when they're faced with the
treaty and these are countries I've and
I would expect to comply and in fact
they do and they cause very few puzzles
for us they're exactly what you would
expect and I pull those countries that
sincere modifiers they support the
treaty from the outset they have a
preference match with the trees a lot of
times the package of treaties that are
already in pores are close to being in
force in their qualities up match very
closely what's required the trees they
don't you do it just much they
anticipate they'll have to change
relatively little on the other hand
there are and that's the upper left-hand
corner but now look at and now look at
the lower right hand corner there are
also a set of countries that we would
not expect to comply and they don't
again we're not very close to here these
are countries that are sincere modifiers
they oppose the contents of the treaty
they and they their preferences are
quite a bit different they anticipate
that they would have to adjust maximally
in some cases were they to ratify and
they don't they stand out they stand
away from the 3d and stay outside of the
receipt China with the International
Covenant on Civil and Political Rights
is a good example of I think a sincere
non rata fire even though I know that
they are in the process of thinking
about what would it take for China to
by the convention the International
Convention on Civil and Political Rights
the real puzzling thing are the cross
diagonals here that's what creates an
interesting puzzle and raises questions
on the one hand we there are a number of
countries out there that you would
expect to comply yet they go and how can
we explain this I call them false
negatives and these countries I argue
often have domestic political
institutions in place that raised the
cost of ratifying and I specify these
intestines empirically in the book they
tend to have high ratification hurdles
countries that require a supermajority
rather than a bare majority for example
to ratify a treaty they tend to be
Federalists countries so countries that
involve a lot of sub-national units
which often has some kind of authority
of competence over the areas that the
treaty tries to regulate and I also make
an argument about the nature of the
legal system I argue that in common law
countries introducing a treaty as a
broad principle from which we can deduce
the right answers is foreign to the way
of sort of legal reasoning in those
countries which is very inductive very
bottom up as well in common law
countries a government has to be
concerned about the way that the treaty
will be interpreted in very powerful
courts with a lot of authority to
broadly interpret the meaning of a legal
obligation and so in those kinds of
legal systems compared to civil law
systems there's a tendency to hang back
and to not readily ratify these treaties
and so it's very clear what the treaty
requires they also tend a lot of
reservations in place as soon
we also have now and by the way one of
the one of the countries that I would
call a false negative in many ways is
the United States we fit a lot of those
criteria and so it's puzzling too many
people why do we have to ratify the
Convention on the Rights of the Child
it's puzzling Vanetta country why we
haven't ratified the convention on the
elimination of discrimination against
women when it seems like children and
women are reasonably well endowed with
rights and protections in this country
that seem quite quite broad and stronger
in many ways than the treaties
themselves so that now what we have down
here in the lower left-hand corner is
the box that really troubles folks who
have studied the international legal
system system of treaties the case in
which we have countries that we don't
expect why they don't be appearing to
make any kinds of efforts to actual
comply with treaty obligations yet they
ratify these are the very irritating
cases they are the cases that appear to
degrade the nature of the obligation
itself and to really cast doubt on the
effect of the international treaty
system these cases I'll able to be false
positives these countries I argue are
engaging in strategic behavior ok so
these countries are trying I argue in
the book to avoid the cost of
international criticism but I'm very
careful to note that this is a strategy
that only works in children ok so this
is a case of trying to achieve social
camouflage trying to do with the other
countries that you normally compare
yourselves with yourself with are doing
and one of the interesting empirical
findings that I found in the book is
that there is a very strong tendency to
ratify treaties if the other countries
in your region with themselves and I
argue that this is because they're
rationally trying to avoid being singled
out as the one laggard on to sort of
stay outside the system because if you
think
on it nongovernmental organizations and
other bodies who might want to criticize
those who stay outside of the treaty
regime have a limited budget they can't
go after everybody they can only go
after laggards and if you know oddly
nobody in the region is ratifying time
sure to pick out one country and
criticize them it's hard to pick out one
country and criticize them and so what
we find for the most convincing
explanation for false positives is that
sort of a dynamic like this ass cooling
effect now this is perfectly rational
here although I don't make any
assumptions about the brain power of
fish but we can't we know what's going
on in this picture we know that they are
schooling because if they were to sort
of sense swim separately they would be
subject to attack by a shark and an
analogy in the international setting is
that states who don't school like this
are subject to attack by Amnesty
International or other nongovernmental
organizations and so it's a rational
thing to do to school to pool to hide to
camouflage oneself among the group that
should normally compare themselves to
and i found this was actually a very
clear empirical regularity what i was
looking at ratification and this could
help to explain why we get false
positives some countries that ratify but
have no intention to really change
according to the treaty so why don't
these strategic grata fires who are just
trying to camouflage themselves
anticipate ratification pressures
well
one reason is they often have
information deficits so I found what I
was looking at this work that a lot of
mimicry went on in regions that have
poor information and I looked at the
degree of freedom of the press for
example in the different regions and
found mimicry really high where the
press was controlled by governments
mimicry was low in regions where the
press was rather more free so
information deficits are one possibility
similarly I found a lot of them agree in
the 1980s before a lot before there was
at north and denser network of
non-governmental organizations that
could criticize and it were away in the
1990s mimicry was a lot less later on
where the information environment was a
lot venture time horizons are another
issue I also found that when you look
just at autocratic governments that they
tended to ratify treaties towards the
end of their term in office the end of
the period that they were in office
sometimes perhaps wanting to leave a
legacy that they had been sort of
liberalize errs at the end but never
wanted to live with the consequences of
AB de actually empowering their
political opposition miscalculation is
another example so when Pinochet
ratified the convention against torture
he probably was not anticipated probably
not calculated that that would be the
very treaty which might have something
to do with his extradition only about a
decade later so basically I argue that
some governments calculate based on
imperfect information and with short
time arises that ratification might be
worth the gamble for some very short
term benefits may be praised maybe
inclusion a positive publicity that
cetera so that's the argument i make
about why states commit themselves the
question that we're all very interested
in those what difference does any
this made and so in order to answer that
question I look very closely at domestic
politics and the argument that I make is
the main argument in the book this isn't
the only argument that i'm just going to
simplify and focus in on one of the
mechanisms that i look at in the book is
that ratify treaties help to mobilize
groups to expect and to demand their
rights and I argue that treaties have
two kinds of effects in countries they
influence values they can have an
educated function that is they can
actually convince people that who have
never thought so before that they could
imagine themselves as rights holders and
in addition they actually increase the
chances of successfully demanding you're
right they turn out to be a legal
resource and they are often can be used
in conjunction for example with
litigation and other strategies to try
to increase the size of the coalition
that begins to demand rights change now
in order to flush this out let's think
first of all why people would mobilize
at all in the first place nevermind a
treaty and the way I think about this is
that people mobilize when the expected
value of mobilizing is high an expected
value really is a function of two things
it's a function of how likely you are to
succeed and how much valium you put on
succeeding and get into those two things
interacting when that's maximized that's
when you're likely to get excited to
mobilize the argument that I make in the
book is that in stable autocracies when
you mobilize you're likely to succeed is
low although on the other hand in a
stable democracy when you mobilize to
demand something
anything you have a relatively much
higher likelihood of succeeding which is
a nature of responsive government almost
by definition what about those you're
valuing success well in a stable
democracy in a democracy that broadly
guarantees a broad number of rights and
in addition has a lot of citizen
participation already the value that you
might place on one additional right on
the margin is likely to be small but the
introduction of the right a new right in
a stable autocracy is potentially
radical it really can introduce
completely mean conceptions of what you
might be able to demand and then
suggests that mobilization you sort of
think of a maximization of the value you
place on mobile on which Adam and
getting it and the likely of the Joseph
see these things are maximized little of
this kind of distribution here across
regime flight by the way I don't
depending on the rights issue area we
don't have to be thinking about
autocracies and democracies we could be
thinking about other dimensions the
general dimension across the bottom is
special hostility towards making the
demand and when I look at women's rights
for example I look very carefully at the
strength of the coalition between
organized religion and state the case of
women's rights off of that is what we
should be looking at along this bottom
scale here and not necessarily a top
receiver system opera see so the
expected value of mobilizing ought to be
somewhere in the middle now what happens
when you introduce a treaty okay so
let's just go back to the original
picture and think about the introduction
of a treaty now in this setting and I
argue that treaties have their most
radical effect on the likelihood of
succeeding in stable democracies they
are a new resource though
legal resource they can sometimes use in
litigation they can grow the size of the
coalition they can help to create a
focal point so that it's clear what
we're demanding and when you when i talk
about growing the size of the coalition
i'm talking about a treaty increasing
the group of those interested in
compliance from just those who might
benefit from compliance with the
treaties to those who might additionally
have other reasons for wanting to comply
so it grows from a pro rights coalition
to pro compliance growing coalition and
oftentimes what we see is that when a
treaty is ratified new groups get on
board that aren't necessarily closely
identified with the right per se Foreign
Ministries the legal profession others
that have an interest in compliance with
the trainee who might not have a real
clear sort of dedicated dedication to
the right itself so it is stable
democracy it increases your likelihood
of succeeding in a stable autocracy a
treaty I'm sorry to say does not
increase your likelihood of succeeding
very much but it does and alter the
value that you might play some success
by introducing a new and radical idea I
didn't know I could I could consider
myself a property owner of my org a
minority might say or I didn't know a
woman might say that I could inherit the
empowerment of my husband and I thought
that it was going to have to go to my
son by the way kicked me out of my party
so to imagine yourself now as our rights
over in a new way is likely to do
radical and a stable autocracy or in
another kind of regime that is possible
to the writing
so what do they see then it surface
asymmetrical shifting of these curves
representing the likelihood of success
values the value placed on a laptop
receipt the value placed on success goes
up and stable democracies the likelihood
of succeeding goes up let me just give
you sort of a sense of what this could
mean it is stable democracy for example
the likelihood of succeeding I argue
that one sort of possibility for
democracies is that they can use the
courts that they can use a tree to
stimulate an inquiry and place questions
beforehand Allah judges and legal so
this is just an example of this
happening in Israel for example a
country I would consider a stable
democracy but one which it has obvious
challenges with respect to its standards
relating to torture okay so this is a
case in which after ratification and
also I should admit after changing the
basic law Rella that comes into closer
compliance with Convention Against
Torture there's a stair as a large bulge
in the number of cases that went to the
Israeli Supreme Court eventually in 1999
Israeli Supreme Court made a landmark
decision and this decision did not make
torture and legal but it did say that if
you are going to torture you're going to
need to change the law to do that well
this means that in the Israeli Knesset
there would have to be along the books
now debated and defended that torture is
a good thing or the torture is in our
interest and that created entirely
dynamic in Israel we can't be the only
country in the world that has legalized
torture by international standards and
so they backed away from that position
never did passed a law to that effect
and if you look at some of the ravings
by
from the coatings that have been done by
political scientists based on State
Department reports as well as Amnesty
International Airport's their torture
practices or at least partially amelie
ater ameliorated after this court
decision it's torture tricky of course
because you can find ways to do it but
don't leave same kinds of marks and
scars and overt kinds of on kinds of
evidence but nonetheless there there did
to seem to be some of the narration in
the practices in Israel after this court
decision another case you could look at
it is the use of the courts in Chile for
example two things are going on in this
particular this is again related to
torture two things are going on go right
in 1997 1998 and she like one is example
the Pinochet example of how powerful the
torture treaty actually is and the use
of that treaty to demonstrate that there
is a possibility for using this treaty
as a legal instrument at the same time
those of you who know the process of
democratization and she lay there is an
important court reform going on in she
lay in 1997 1998 as well it was a period
in which the cronies from the Pinochet
regime were great extent cleared out and
the courts became incredible places to
actually put these torture cases before
a panel of judges so these are
conditional arguments this isn't
available everywhere courts are not a
realistic option everywhere there a
realistic option though where you have a
thoroughly independent court system and
by 1990
8g they did have that all right so what
this is basically I think arguing when
you think of both of those pervs go up
is that the motive and the means to
mobilize and the influence that a treaty
actually adds when those two branches
for those two curves kind of move up
asymmetrically is that introducing a
treaty has a stronger impact on
mobilization not in a stable at offices
where you will be crushed and not in the
stable democracies where you already
enjoy 99 right now we're talking about a
hundred but instead in the countries in
between that are transitioning may be
volatile um you know make it out very
democratic in which introducing a treaty
I really stimulates groups that now
think they can increasingly succeed and
believe that there's a there's a value
to try to do so um and this just simply
shows us this is a result of a
regression that shows that the
correlation between ratifying the treaty
and the mobilization of groups gets
stronger and more positive after
ratification and this is controlling for
a lot of okay so basically this puts now
the number of women's international
nongovernmental organizations on the
left-hand side of a multiple regression
and puts ratification of the treaty and
a lot of other variables on the right
hand side to give you a sense that
twaddle that groups mobilized once
there's been a ratification this is a
period where you can actually influence
implementation they get excited to
participate and to do so
alright so my expectation though is a
treaty should have their greatest and
most positive impact in the more fluid
transitional and partially democratic
regimes now let me show you some
evidence related to the torture machine
the book contains chapters on civil and
political rights women's rights and
children's rights but the only thing
that we had the least bit of time
formula in the few minutes remaining is
the area of torture so I just want to
give you a little bit of evidence on
this so this is the scale that I use to
try to examine the incidence of torture
and they intensity really of torture I
don't believe it makes any sense to
count tortures I don't believe that but
it does make sense to put states in two
broad categories and we can make these
categories based on two kinds of
databases that now have a good long
history one of the country reports of
Amnesty International and the other are
the reports that are put together by the
state and they use language like this as
you can see up here that can help us to
categorize face from those are the
absolute worst where torture is
prevalent widespread repeated and
methodical where folks are abused to get
commonly frequently and it's a
widespread practice that's category
number 12 category number 5 where we can
see summons of psychological
mistreatment and the isolated for
example and there's usually a punishment
or some kind of follow-up a disciplinary
cholera involved we can think of
categories in between the 42 the scale
now if you were to grasp this scale and
you were to graph the proportion of
states that have ratified the convention
against torture you would get something
like this with the torture scale on the
left-hand side and the countries who
have ratified the cat on the right-hand
side
little drifting down over time in the
scale which we might want to discuss by
the way it could reflect changing norms
it could reflect that what we used to
consider torture in the 1980s now we
would include many other things in
torture in torture as well so it could
be more on it says late some drift
downward would be better information the
more we know the more we find out ok
because torture after all is something
governments try to hide I don't okay so
what I looked at this evidence and when
I did a multiple regression again
controlling for a lot of other things is
after all signing a treaty is hardly
going to become the influence
unfortunate practices nobody would think
so so instead it's important to design a
test in which you carefully control for
other obvious explanations in addition a
test where you control for the things or
the conditions that explain ratification
of the treaty in the first place and met
those away so we're no longer just
saying oh whatever made you ratify the
treaty explains that you were on your
ways and not torturing anyway once we've
developed a model which takes care of
those obvious objections we can look at
the relationship between the
ratification of the convention against
torture and its effects positive is an
improvement here on the scale and the P
equals something relates to the
probability that the estimate we're
getting on the effect is any different
than zero okay so what we have on
countries that have never been
Democratic no effect this could just be
zero with a little bit of noise around
zero no effect to ratify the treaty
stable democracies a little bit of a
positive effect but we can't
from 0 to much noise too much variation
he finds something difficult in the
transitional countries here we find that
there is probably about a ninety four
percent chance that this positive
improvement in the torture scale is not
to the chance alone that there's a
systemic relationship these we ratify
the treaty and the improvement I'm a
torturer scale now what I'm just showing
you as a correlation that's all that I'm
showing but once you've taken out all
these other possible explanations and
once you try to develop a model that
explains radical to identification of
the treaty in the first place but I
think you're left with you know a
stronger inference that there's might be
something causal behind this correlation
let me draw a few conclusions and then
invite your questions in your comments
because of the commentators as well very
quickly human rights treaties I think
may have really contributed strongly in
some cases to an improvement of rights
around the world um you know we can't
say conclusively that they have and one
over we don't know the net effects are
there any negative pushback effects that
I haven't been able to model very
successfully the effects differ across
countries there is no one homogeneous
effect across all countries but it's
really concentrated in these
transitional countries they did they
offer they also the effects of
ratification also differ quite a bit
depending on the right that you're
talking about I only had time to show
you torture the effects differ across
some of these other issue areas and then
finally the policy implication is that
at least in countries that have had some
experience or have some possibility of
an experience with responsive government
that it makes sense to encourage the
ratification of these treaties not only
that it would make good sense if
countries like the United States would
use their rhetoric and their material
resources to show that they support
these treaties as well because it seems
like the least you can do to sort of
give those on the ground some
possibility of trying to achieve their
own interests when it
to their rights realizations so I'd like
now to I guess turn it over to the
commentators and invite your comments
thanks Beth you really managed to
capture the essence of the 400-page book
and a good job so our first discussing
is ken raw
okay well thank you very much for a very
interesting presentation an interesting
book I'm I'm not going to say what you I
think prediction i would say which you
know I mean I at a certain level
naturally I think treaties matter
ratification of treaties matter of you
know so I don't I don't find that a
controversial proposition and I'm happy
that you were able to prove that you
know um but I'm going to I mean I also
understand sort of the political context
in which you thought it was important to
pursue that because I realized that
there are some who claim not only do
treaties or not matter but that
ratification is negative and you know
taking the I mean I guess the case where
that would come out most acutely would
be your false positives and and I agree
with you that that that's a short-term
strategy you know that that perhaps for
a moment ratification could deflect
pressure but it's it's not a long-term
strategy because you know over time the
human rights movement will get to that
country and and the ratification won't
help I actually think it's interesting
the point you made about autocrats doing
this toward the end I would interpret
that differently I mean I you know where
as you know an elected government knows
when the end is almost a definition of
an autocrat is that they don't know when
the end is they're trying to cling to
power and and so you know if indeed
ratifications of autocrats tend to come
toward the end of what in retrospect we
know was the the conclusion of their
regime it may have been sort of a last
ditch effort to cling to power and that
you know as the pressure is building for
them to step down they may have sort of
offered this as you know one last effort
to legitimize their rule which failed
you know since we know was at the end
but anyway that's a small point um I i'm
going to my main thesis here is is I
think different from what you would
expect me to say and and that is that um
perhaps I can only say that because I'm
a lawyer but I don't think the law
matters nearly as much as the underlying
norms and and to just to kind of you
know to put this in perspective
when I think about you know taking on a
country or taking on an issue I have to
admit that I have never in my 22 years
of Human Rights Watch begun by asking
has the country ratified a treaty it
just doesn't enter the calculation and
um I can um you know I guess the you
know your schooling metaphor was
interesting and and maybe you know if
there's do if it's due to an information
deficit it may be that they don't really
understand how we work or maybe you know
there are other factors going on but but
when we consider sort of you know what
issues are what countries to take on
we're much more concerned with you know
are we going to be able to highlight a
discrepancy between the government's
conduct and some norm some pretense that
it feels obliged to follow and the
treaty can manifest that but it's it's
not for me the most the most salient
factor in all of us now I'll explain
that a little bit let me just you know
first by way of caveats say that um I do
think that treaties have been important
if for no other reason that they have
helped to legitimize the human rights
venture as a whole and and if you know
we were still in the era where
governments were able to say that you
know talking about human rights is
interfering in their internal affairs
which you know you still get get
glimmers of for now and then but it's a
totally discredited argument and it
doesn't get you know people anything if
I think it's treaties that have helped
to undermine that argument and so um
just you know whether any particular
government is ratified the fact that so
many governments have ratified so many
human rights treaties shows that the
discussion of how a government treats
its people is a legitimate conversation
at the international level I mean that's
tremendously important the other thing
that I think is important and this is a
corollary of that is that much of the
way the human rights movement puts
pressure on an abuse of government is by
getting influential third
party governments to put pressure on the
target and that pressure can come
through you know conditionality in in
terms of aid it can become coming in the
form of you know the veu cooperation
agreements where there's you know kind
of a standard clause and they're
requiring respect for human rights and
democracy it can come at the level of
you know whether it's appropriate to you
know invite to autocrat so-and-so to
your next fancy summit you know I mean
they could get these kinds of pressure
comes up in a lot of different ways but
it is now kind of an accepted part of
what it means to be a sort of
responsible international player that
governments have to at least pretend to
treat human rights is one significant
element of their foreign policy they
talk about it it's a factor in there you
know in their bilateral relations and so
you know that that also i think is to a
degree a product of treaties now I I
don't want to overstate that because and
I think there's one very good part of
your book you deliberately don't look at
state to state compliance and I think
you you rightly write that off it's not
where it's at because I mean if you look
at sort of the formal state to state
compliance mechanisms they are hardly
ever used I mean I think the best
example of that which is not technically
a human rights treaty but it's a as a
humanitarian law treaty the the first
Additional Protocol to the geneva
conventions which today is you know sort
of the principal treaty governing modern
warfare has in article 90 the curry of
you mentioned this in your book a
fact-finding Commission that was
established where whenever there is sort
of a contested issue states can ask for
this back binding Commission to go and
investigate what happened you know where
war crimes committed and I forget when
it was created but he has it's been 20
years or something and it's never been
used you know or or to take another
example the main u.s. strategy to try to
prevent the International Criminal Court
from having real bite was to try to
insist that the only two ways that the
court could be seized of a case was
either through the security council
where the US can control the process of
it
veto or through a state complaint and
the u.s. knew that you know states don't
complain to each other or do so in rare
instances they fought tooth and nail to
avoid the prosecutor on his own PL
abrasions and and that's because they
realized the state to stay compliances
is not you know it's not the key factor
here now you know I recognize that in
places like the Human Rights Council you
do get States speaking out against other
states but it tends to be against
adversaries you know it's it's not it's
not a reliable mean of enforcement in in
a more routine situation now the in in
the book you talk about customary
international law and and that's it may
you know missed it i have to do but i
did my sense was that when you thought
of norms you mainly thought about custom
in that sense it's really just kind of
another dimension of the law but one
that's not codified and for me you know
while customary international law has
its role i mean for example the US has
never ratified you know the first
Additional Protocol but it complies with
it because it considers most of the
customs so it's not irrelevant but um
for me the norms that matter much more
are at the level of sort of what you
might call public morality just you know
what do people think is right or wrong
and and you know that that population
can be ideally would be within the the
target country but at times there can be
a surrogate public so if you have a sort
of a significant aid relationship and
you can convince you know another public
to change that aid relationship or to
condition it you can move a target
country even if public morality hasn't
evolved sufficiently in the target
country but you know when I think about
sort of the different types of rites I
mean I guess put let me put it this way
I think would be useful in your analysis
to to distinguish among different types
of rights in terms of how firm the sort
of the common public understood norm his
and so you know at one extreme i would
put things like you know torture or
summary executions where there is just
you know broad public record
these are wrong and and my hypothesis
would be that in those situations on
treaties matter the least I also would
guess that treaties matter less when the
right as codified is subject to
interpretation and so if you think take
something like the right to freedom of
speech or the right to freedom of
assembly these are so qualified in terms
of you know various reason they taught
that the you know the government can can
qualify them security concerns Public
Order public health what have you that
you know again it's it's it's often the
treaty gets you sort of only so far and
you end up having to debate you know
what is the meaning of this norm in a
certain context and there again I think
that again it's the public morality that
probably matters much more my guess
would be than the treaty itself we're
ratification i would think matters a lot
is where the norm itself is very
contestant and so you know for me I
would look at things like women's rights
religious rights sexual rights rights
where there really is not universal
acceptance at the public level so that
if a government ratifies that's a major
statement and it is sort of settling a
cultural dispute in a way that there's
really not a lot too subtle when the
issue is torture so you know I would to
qualify this further I think that the I
mean to use the sort of the three types
of effects that you see treaties having
her ratification having you know one
setting the agenda to creating legal
mechanisms or legal opportunities and
three opportunities for social
mobilization I would think that a
ratification matters most with respect
to legal remedies and that's almost by
definition you know that if you are
going to appeal to a court whether it's
a domestic court or for that matter in
international court you know to have
chapter and verse I've actually you know
the treaty legally binding des matter
and so you would expect it to you no
matter um you know in the european union
or for that matter in Latin America
where the inter-american Court is
increasingly playing a significant role
now I recognize that these are also the
government's to tend to be more
democratic so there may be other factors
at play that reduce the significance of
having that legally recognized right but
you know I think that the you know I do
see your thesis having significance
where the tool is is legal but in terms
of agenda-setting as well as social
mobilization what I would you know
suggesting it maybe I couldn't really
have just not well enough first in the
sort of the mathematical side of this to
know what all this meant but I you know
and maybe have already sort of tested
for this but I would when I look through
your list I didn't see it there and and
that is you know is an alternative
explanation that there is a strong
public norm as opposed to that the
government is ratified and in this maybe
it's kind of a cause and effect question
I mean has the movement toward
ratification at least assuming some
degree of sincerity using your core part
scheme there is that more product of the
emergence of norms and and as the put it
another way is this the significance
with respect to behavior is that come
more from the existence of the norm or
from the existence of the treaty and I
you know I say this because you know
again I when you look at how the at
least two only begin with the
international human rights movement we
almost by definition don't use
litigation you know if there's kind of a
an ACLU the local version of the ACLU
that can handle the matter we stay away
I mean groups like Human Rights Watch or
amnesty international are basically non
litigation organizations and so you know
we use shaming we use you know various
forms of pressure from third-party
governments and you know for those to
work my sense is the existence of this
norm matters much more than the
existence of radical
and while you know there is an educative
role to ratification again it's just
thinking intuitively my sense is that it
matters much less than other factors in
terms of building you know public
disapproval of a particular governmental
practice um you know similarly with
respect to mobilization if you're
mobilizing to well I guess even there's
worth dividing mobilization into to sort
into two types I mean on the one end if
the mobilization is is simply to put
pressure on the governor and get a lot
of people in the streets I actually
don't think either the norm or the legal
right matters that much I mean if you're
succeed in getting enough people on the
street you'll move the government to
change his behavior but if the the aim
is is more of a shaming one then my
sense is that the existence of sort of
some public sense that government should
operate a certain way matters more than
whether that government has ratified a
particular treaty or not and I can't
prove this but this is just kind of
intuitively as I look it sort of you
know the factors that seem to go into
both domestic rights and international
rights organizations we really are
looking more at areas where a government
it is under some expectation of a
certain behavior quite apart from the
seeming technicality of whether it's
ratified or not let me just make one
final point about where I think treaties
matter the most and this is not in the
case of any of the six treaties that you
were looking at but where I think
treaties are most important is where you
already have a treaty but it's ambiguous
as to what's required and so I mean to
give an example which is I realize it
may be a notch away from what you were
looking at but if you take the the
concept of indiscriminate warfare um
there is a treaty that prohibits
indiscriminate warfare that's what you
know the first additional protocols and
jeevika mentions des hommes nonetheless
that prohibition which was broadly
ratified and also accepted as customary
international law was able to coexist
with the widespread use of
anti-personnel landmines which are
inherently indiscriminate weapon because
they
have no idea who's going to step on them
and it could be a soldier but it could
just be an ordinary civilian now you
know if you had gone to court and said
you know judge please outlaw landmines
because they're indiscriminate you would
pretty much gotten thrown out of court
because even though you know a simple
reading of the protocol would say well
yes and discriminant he seemed to be
indiscriminate there was a parallel
treaty that was sort of regulating
landmines rather than prohibiting them
and the judge would have said well you
know there's a separate legal regime so
clearly the the drafters of the protocol
we're thinking to outlaw landmines when
they adopted this provision on
indiscriminate warfare so sorry you lose
and so in that circumstance what was
required was a new treaty a treaty that
basically said that land mines are
indiscriminate the same thing happened
with with cluster munitions it was very
much the same process or to take another
example the child soldiers if you had
gone to court and 15 years ago and said
I want to you know sue my government for
using 15 year old kids or 16 year old
kids let's say as soldiers you would
have lost because the Geneva Conventions
actually contemplated using people 16 22
18 0 16 and 17 and it took a new treaty
basically you know redefining what a
child was for military purposes to raise
the bar and to kind of reinterpret the
otherwise permissive standards of the
Geneva Conventions now with what these
three examples have in common each of
them we went to a very similar process
I'm it began with fact-finding you know
we did we investigated a lot of
situations where land mines were used
your child soldiers were used or cluster
munitions were used and we built public
outrage at this practice and we showed
the kind of the human toll of these
practices that led to a norm you know
people began to think it was wrong to
use landmines it was wrong to use child
soldiers
that Norm proceeded any treaty it was
from that norm that we were slowly able
to mobilize civil society and then
ultimately governments to adopt a treaty
and that new treaty then have
reinterpreted the broad provisions of
the the week or more general treaty that
pre-existed now the questions we're in
that process did government behavior
change and my sense is that for the most
part government behavior it began to
switch with the creation of the norm and
it completely switched by the time we
got a treaty but before anybody had
ratified and so you know at the moment
that the treaty was adopted um you know
land mine use had stopped and and then
over the next few years governments
began to ratify but that it was you know
it was the the norm process and then the
kind of the formal process of having a
treaty that mattered much more than the
commitment of any given government and
indeed you know government like the
United States which is never committed
to the land mines treaty wouldn't dare
use land mines today because the norm is
so strong and so um you know this is I
mean there's just one example but it's
part of what makes me think that it you
know i i'd be interested in sort of how
your analysis played out if there's a
way to do this to measure not simply the
commitment which is the focus but rather
the existence of kind of strong public
expectations about governmental conduct
and and while i did i would expect the
treaty to matter much more in a society
where litigation is possible there are
in many many countries in the world
where the courts are weak and where it
is really only public pressure or
mobilization that is going to get things
done and in those circumstances my
hypothesis would be that the norm is
more important than the treaty it's all
stop there
thanks again I was so worried that you
were going to agree with that about
everything and thank goodness you did so
Alex Fuli yes thanks I will be brief
because I know there are a lot of
questions in the audience the book is
great you have a sense of that I think
already from presentation just the scope
of it the empirics the nuance is really
fabulous in this book and and what I
really appreciate a lot is sort of the I
beth has for macro trends and you don't
pick this up so much in the
presentations but in the book she she
she singles out a number of episodes
that seem to be innocuous or
insignificant and then really looks at
some of the long-term downstream effects
that these have for mobilization and so
forth so for instance you know 1974 1976
US congressional decision to tie foreign
aid to rights seem like a very limited
type of mood but had all these
consequences and in terms of creating a
demand for information gathering to see
if you're in compliance with these
provisions so the book is is excellent
for a number of different reasons but i
think the text itself is very nuanced
it's not just about sort of regression
equations and running the numbers and
sort of you know the kind of rigorous
empirical work Beth does she really
looks at the evolution of the
sovereignty regime and international law
the evolution of mechanisms of
accountability and verification as well
as providing theories of ratification on
ratification compliance and
non-compliance and there's I think a
modesty due to the book that that's
that's very very welcome the thing I
like most about the book theoretically
is that it's it's very political now
that seems strange coming from political
science but one of the reasons that
people like me are particularly
skeptical of a lot of the stuff that
comes out is you hear arguments like
norms produce so and so
or states coerce so and so right this
arguments a lot more sophisticated about
that and involves the stuff of domestic
political contestation right treaties
change politics it's a very central
contention in best book that is once you
pass a tree politics can't be the same
right everything else is not equal so
the interaction of domestic politics
domestic institutional structures gives
us some insights into sort of these
false negatives and false positives by
the way the the false negatives
discussion I found fascinating because I
I think about false positives a lot I
examine Eurasia and I had always assumed
well why doesn't the United States you
know sign these things well of course
its hegemonic power it's the George Bush
administration but actually uh I was
pretty convinced that you know what
common law and federalism really are
part of the story and your observation
that this applies to children rather
treatise on women and children I think
lends credence to that this is not just
a national security issue even though we
sort of tried to defend it that way and
the Australian example I think is also
convincing within those terms so that
part of it I really like so the question
then gets the sort of false positives
right you know why do governments sign
on the things that are obviously not in
their interests are obviously going to
come back to haunt them and and Beth
talk I think it gives very plausible
mcnamee short time horizons you know the
need for sort of you know short-term
benefits like strategic acceptance and
so forth I think the real theoretical
contribution of the book is separating
out differential consequences of this
across different policy polities and and
and this sort of category of
transitional Anna cratic whatever term
you want to use a country's is key and
its key because of the institutional
instability that we see in them and and
that there's a line of the conclusion
where you sort of nicely summarized this
but if I I think you could even sort of
emphasize this more that the common
feature that we see in these polities of
in
tutions are up for grabs they're in flux
whether it be the relationship of the
courts to the system whether it's the
independence of Parliament visa V the
executive process of decentralization
you don't mention it but I would include
that in the list to sort of empowering
sort of local governments and the way
local communities do daisy chains around
central government's and invoke sort of
international law and entreaties and so
forth this is what happened to polities
and flux and so a lot of this has a lot
of the mechanism Beth is talking about
is actors for their own political
purposes not stick as the normatively
committed I don't want to take that out
of the equation and I think n is right
to point that out but a lot of actors
for their own political purposes
mobilize around this and I think that's
what I find deeply satisfying about this
type of explanation my big set of
questions or comments really strikes at
the heart of this regionalism issue I
think this is key and and that describes
this could we be seeing a kind of a
rational school of fish kind of
phenomenon here for the false positives
you sort of comply everyone else
complies and you sort of hide in the
background and you know you don't want
to be singled out and here I think
there's a little bit of room for
pushback on behalf of Sir social
constructivist that is what you test
seems to be strategic ratification
versus socialization but socialization
in the very deep sense of the world
right the internalization of an oil
right the adoption of this and there's
also a kind of one degree removed school
of social thought talked about sort of
social influence right and under social
influence models rule standards and
behaviors are not internalized or
believed but they're adopted to conform
with the pack for prestige reasons for
status reasons right I think it's very
plausible that if we think if states
think of themselves as part of a group
that's certainly true of Eastern Europe
it's certainly true the Baltics
certainly true of central asia regional
leaders also think of themselves as
group members and they think about who
has the status in the group and who
doesn't I don't want to be labor they
announce because it's a very kind of
political science ii issue but i guess
i'm not convinced that social camouflage
really is a
I tend to see it more in the kind of
social influence category I guess what
would be the single distinguishing
feature that that has so what why does
this matter I think the fact that the
Central Asian countries Armenian
Azerbaijan is there on a chart that Beth
has has signed all six core treaties
without entering reservations or
declarations is really good evidence
that they're going through the motions
right that it's exactly because they
don't have reservations right that they
seem to be engaging in this form of
mimicry right yeah whatever we'll do it
we don't want to stand out we don't want
to draw attention to us and so forth and
thinking about the post-communist world
we also start thinking about the
different influences and the variable
influences then that these social groups
have and I think there's two distinct at
least two distinct social groups one is
Eastern Europe and the Baltics their
social pole and the European pole was
over determined right yes treaty
compliance they were democracies but
they were facing a lot of conditions
from the EU a lot of conditions from
NATO from the transatlantic community I
think this works in tandem with your
argument and I think actors actually in
terms of invoking EU conditionality did
so very strategically to sort of throw
out autocrats or uncommitted Democrats
and so forth Central Asian and the
Caucasus seems to have a different
regional pole right initially there was
this kind of school of fish dynamic but
now we're seeing a pool in the opposite
direction and the backlash against human
rights the backlash against the OECD its
office for Democratic initiatives as
their human rights commitments some
people have argued that this is at the
behest of Russia this is an example sort
of sovereign democracy that this has
intensified as competing models such as
China have risen so again that's a
school of fish kind of dynamic where is
that kind of a sort of following a of a
status and prestige influence
whether it be sort of Moscow or burry
Jing as a justification for what they're
doing or not doing so the regional
dimension of this is is is critical and
I think in the post-communist world you
see very different regional influences
and that's going to determine their
long-term commitments of these things
finally just very briefly a question for
Beth and a question for Ken and can I
I'm not supposed to be your discussion
since your captive here you're going to
get the question anyway the question for
Beth is how can we tell what are the one
or two indicators that you would sort of
point to and say AHA a country has moved
from being don't even bother about it to
the influence of Oh category is it that
they have a outgrowth of sort of civil
society that there's a regime collapse
that there's a degree of freedom of the
press I mean what one or two features
would you say are the most important to
thinking that these sort of strategies
by activists or court strategies could
be sort of influential what would should
we look for and can what are the
implications of Beth's findings
regarding the hard authoritarian cases
and Human Rights Watch's strategies does
it make sense to conduct certain
advocacy activities about compliance
empower local NGOs and information
gatherers when they face such daunting
obstacles when they might be tried
imprisoned all the things that of course
you're you're all too aware of is the
implication here provocative one that
human rights watching groups like it
should instead wait for real tactical
opportunities that are presented by
either domestic violence or regional
developments right revolution in
Kyrgyzstan opens the door again to
talking about who's Becca stand in a way
that hasn't been possible for four or
five years and so forth so I'll leave it
that thank you so what I'm proposing to
do now is to
have Beth respond to any one or two
points that the discussants have raised
then f10 to respond to alex's question
and while they're doing that people in
the audience please line up at the mic
because you'll get your turn for your
question in just a minute so fast all
right okay I think from from Ken I think
it's important really to respond to this
question the primary question really was
laced throughout most of your
presentation ken was this idea of you
know are they really responding to the
broader norms or to the ratification per
se and I want to re-emphasize the
reasons why from the point of view of a
domestic person on the ground the
ratification is really important okay
and let me let me admit that from the
point of view of Amnesty International
it's not so important okay but but look
look at what of the what are the
advantages that ratification does for
you if you are a local living in a
country it pre commits the government
okay and by pre committing the
government that is with a public vote
well in many countries of public vote in
some cases not a public vote actually
but some other kind of public form of
commitment it actually gives you
ammunition that this is legitimate
locally this is really an important
point because it is very easy for
precisely the reasons that Alex outlines
for groups within a country or for a
government to push back against the West
right to push back against amnesty
international to push back against
Western norms and to find very
attractive alternative maybe Eastern
norms or other forms of norms but to
ratify is to indigenous to a certain
extent okay to indigenous by saying we
agree this is legitimate and so I think
I think that's an advantage that you
have by ratification if you are on the
ground that would make any difference to
Amnesty International but if you are
living in the country and trying to
think of a strategy for making demands
that's a huge factor to have in your
favor it also sort of contra the idea of
norms matter it helps to spell things
out and put them in very clear focus I
can think of specific rights that it
would be very hard to sort of coalesce
around had it not been in a treaty and
one of the things I can think of for
example is that we didn't even talk
about women's rights for example in here
but an entire chapter I have deals on
that the right woman's right to
reproductive health for example not sort
of just a norm floating around out there
sort of freeform but something's very
concrete in a treaty that women for
example women in Colombia pointed to and
lobbied for specifically during the
Constitutional Convention said we want
this language about a right to
reproductive health care in our
constitution and it was made and put
into their constitution and that again
creates a platform for a legitimate
demand and not just a big western demand
of some kind and again poses the
possibility of litigation so I so I'm
going to speculate that ratification
matters more to the locals than it does
to Amnesty International Amnesty
International has some other tools they
can leverage third parties to a certain
extent although I want to put a little
footnote on that because third parties
don't care anywhere near as much as the
people on the ground third parties can
be very fickle based on their foreign
policy objectives based on their funding
priorities based on all kinds of things
that would cause them you know would
cause them to back off from rights when
it's not convenient not you know sorry
cost-effective from their point of view
or when the when they sort of light of
publicity sort of goes and it different
Anu Anu crisis over here instead of over
there well it's locals on the ground
over here that constantly care about it
and that's why to them it's it's very
important to i doin digitize these
rights and and that's what ratification
helps to do on Alex um you know I like
his argument about about backlash and
Central Asian I think that's very true
and that's again why ratification is
quite important is that it
kicks that excuse out from under a
government for not complying they was
imposed on us by the West no no no you
ratified you accepted as legitimate so
we're going to hold you to that so I
think I think that's a very good and
helpful point on Alex's question when is
a country convince a ball no one
indicator is possible anything I say is
going to be inadequate but I would say
that that when they start to tolerate
and acknowledge the legitimacy of
opposition is when that door starts to
crack open just a little bit which is
quickly I mean in terms of but the
argument is sort of spelling out rights
I agree that it's important that a right
is spelled out in a treaty but that's
true whether or not there's ratification
and so if you want to know you know what
what you know what are women's rights
you can look to see doll but um you know
in terms of defining the right the
ratification isn't critical now where I
do think you know ratification matters
as I said I think on something like
women's rights where they were much more
contested to have a government commits
to then abide by them can have in a real
behavioral consequences I think it
matters much less in the realm of
torture where you know whether or not
they ratified no government's going to
sort of claim the right to torture and
so I think that you know I think it
really you almost have to look at the
kind of like that we're talking about in
terms of assessing the significance of
the of the ratification itself I'm Alex
introduce your question when you know
what you do with the heart authoritarian
governments there I mean I I do think
that local pressure ultimately is is
determinative and so you know if you
don't have civil society you try to do
two things I mean you know one is you
you gradually try to create space so
they're so local civil society can
emerge but second you pay much more
attention to third-party pressure and
indeed one of the major focuses of that
pressure usually is one of two things
it's either you know aimed at creating
that civil society space or it's aimed
at curtailing the worst kinds of
atrocities well and so for example if
you take you know your Central Asia
caucuses example I actually don't think
what they're
objecting to our the you know the
so-called Western norms they at this
point they want to be a member of the
OSCE they just don't want the OSCE
enforcement mechanisms and so they're
not challenging the standards right now
they're challenging things like
deploying police monitors or deploying
investigative teams and and that's you
know that's that's that's enforcement
that's not the norm itself ok so we're
close to our advertising ending time but
we will take a couple of questions if
you have them and please stand at the
mic
well thank you for the for the
presentation I haven't read the book I
was intrigued by the false-positive
section so if I understand you well
there are different situations I mean
those who are who ratified because they
are misinformed or because they are
simply stupid to put it bluntly or who
are who have incentives of different
sort or pressure status as an incentive
now how do you how do you address
situations of good weather I mean for a
certain period of time there is no
problem to ratify say the Genocide
Convention Rhonda before 94 and how do
you address the situation of double
standards by powerful players I mean if
I know that US doesn't care about
torture well spinach etta will ratify
cynically so it's not nothing of those
situations you described and yeah what
is the impact of double standards on
your on your scheme the world is rife
with double standards they are
everywhere they are in particular among
the false negatives and especially among
the dog's paws talk is the fourth
positive so what do we so your question
is what do we do about double standards
right or what do know what is the impact
of double standards on false positives
and then the consequence on mobile
mobilizing the US game long sorry are
you asking that the double standards
like in the United States with respect
to human right yeah a strong strong
player has a double standard and then
you have a country where the government
ratifies because yeah it
knows that there is a double standard so
it doesn't care it is cynical and and
then the consequence of mobilizing local
people because those local people they
are of course so sufficiently
sophisticated to understand what
ratification means in this particular
context I mean I wouldn't stand up on
the peanut chat regime as it was during
the time of ratification of the
convention well a lot of people did
actually though what was the interested
but the effect of double standards is to
create a sort of expectation that
nothing will be done and so it actually
allows for the potential of more false
positives and this is precisely what we
saw in the earlier years of many of
these treaties so like in the 70's 1980s
when we were a period in which the Cold
War for example convinced a lot of
countries that we're buddies with the
United States we can ratify they're not
going to do anything to us despite the
fact that they demand you knows our
human rights standards in there I see
it's not going to come down on us they
need a strategically and everything else
where their allies and I think that is a
kind of condition that has led to a
period in which a number of countries
ratified just two for the short-term
gains involved and it turns out that
this you know it doesn't stand for long
because the international rights
community ends up exposing the fact that
there's a double standard there but it
does open up this expectation that maybe
I can get away with it by the last point
I was intrigued was costly law actually
customary law the effect of customary
law I mean let's take a Rome Statute for
example I mean most of the contents of
the Rome Statute are customary law so if
I ratify as a government and
authoritarian it's kind of fatalism also
because I have any way no choice whether
I ratify or not the law will apply one
day if I'm thinking
the rome statute is a sort of a
different case because it doesn't
require mobilization domestically or
anything else to really have some kind
of an enforcement power so what I'm
talking about our treaties in which the
most likely mechanism for their
enforcement is likely to be on the
ground in the domestic context
enforcement at the domestic level the
Roman statutes quite the opposite
enforcement is precisely external in
that case except if you take into
account of course the the
complementarity provisions of the Rome
Statute thank you so let's collect both
of the last questions and respond to
them together thank you for a
stimulating discussion um I want to ask
you about perhaps a more enigmatic
example that the case of Russia which I
have some personal experience with and
it's not a treaty that you covered but
the example of the European Convention
on Human Rights I think that it would be
we could make the case that when Russia
ratify this treaty with sincere rata
fire but that may have changed at the
same time there is sort of a very
dedicated community in Russia that's
highly mobilized behind the rights that
this convention bodies but it's a very
small but highly mobilize communion with
in the country and so my question is
more in a different position now and the
sincerity of Russia with respect to
these obligations is it's much more in
question and so I was wondering if you
had sort of any understanding with your
model of how to understand which way the
cookie will crumble you know what are
the important things to look at it and
figuring out what you know what might
happen what are the important things
that the the leaves of these countries
are looking at you thank you hi thank
you for speaking tonight I have a
question regarding local legislation in
terms of City ballots because I was
wondering if any of your in any of your
research or data analyses if you use
city legislation to compare country data
such as the Seattle right to healthcare
ballot initiative or the co-op
in San Francisco or a local minimum wage
higher for domestic workers here in New
York what kind of impact does that have
on federal leaders legislation or any
impact as far as a visual impact around
the world thank you thank you I'm very
impressed by professor mr. Roth's
question raising the public opinions
because that the controversy between
process Simmons and mr. Bros seems to be
metallurgical one I mean they dip mr.
boss raise the morale issue about to
free that that is not observable and but
it will call into a raise a question
whether how particles science come deal
with moral issue which is not observable
or it is quite difficult to say Corey
qualified qualified so my question is my
question to prepare mr. Watts is how can
you prove the public opinion is more
important than treaty and my question to
professor Simmons is how moral issue can
be fit into your theory thank you
okay well I let's just I guess start
with a question of Russia and you know
here the issue is sort of thinking about
Russia you know involved in various
kinds of political and regime change
that would make it a sort of no longer
interested in being held to its
ratification obligations that maybe at
one point it was a sincere rata fire and
now it no no longer is and you know that
that many of these regimes are still in
flux when I sort of say who the sincere
rata fires are and since your nan rata
fires that's at the time of ratification
basically there is nothing in these
treaties it's going to prevent
underlying political change I mean if we
think that's going to happen it's not
it's it's the kind of thing in which
these treaties could at a minimum I
think and maybe even at a maximum prove
useful to make a case or a claim that
despite important you know regime
changes in political changes that
nonetheless it's in it's important to
try to live up to these obligations and
I would expect completely that as a sort
of other indicators of democracy and
rule of law begin to send a great that
the obligation to to live up to a treaty
obligation would as well so all of the
all of the models that I look at like
control for the level of democracy for
example and control for things like
Civil War which is not the Russian
situation at all but control for other
kinds of facts you know conditions that
we know affect human rights because I
don't think we can expect magic out of
these treaties there the European
Convention is not going to prove magic
in Russia any more than these treaties
do it in any other circumstance what I'm
trying to argue is that they proved
useful for those who want to try to
press their rights and I would imagine
that in the Russian case the locals
would make as much use as they possibly
could make out of the European invention
and at the margins it will help that I
won't reverse you know sort of broadly
deteriorating trends in Russia that is
that is to imagine way to lunch
in terms of the power of treaties I
don't have an answer to local
legislation in cities of course I don't
have any data on this one can imagine a
completely different kind of a research
project in which the unit of analysis
was the city instead of the country and
to look to see whether some of these
ordinances about discrimination and
minimum wage have some kind of local
impact there would be a different kind
of a research focus but you could
imagine using some of the same kinds of
same kinds of sort of theoretical
accounts that I've used at the national
level so you'd expect those who want a
minimum wage to wave around the the
resolution of the City Council for
example or the ordinance you would
expect them to point to that and say
this is what our city stands for this is
what you said you're going to do and in
any event when they actually find
behaviors that are that are against
their sort of own passed statutes that
would be very useful to have a very
explicit commitment on the part of the
city but I don't have an answer because
that's not something I've actually
looked at the one could imagine a
parallel city or a similar study that
looked at the domestic level public
opinion hard to codify so the issue here
is that you know sort of how do we
handle this sort of issue that you know
maybe the public just sort of all behind
it and the treaty doesn't tip anything
it's a little hard to explain my results
if that's the case because the treatment
that every country is getting to look
for the change in practices is the
ratification so it sort of flies in the
face of the empirical results to sort of
use that before and after treaty
ratification if we think that it's
something much broader like public
opinion and and you know I have no doubt
that public opinion plays some kind of
role the point is it's not swamp
entreaty effect it's very well in place
but it very well may be in place but the
treaty effect is something that is
distinguishable from what may very well
be going on in the background because
say the same thing about sort of broader
international
orms the universal declarations in the
background the whole time right but it's
actually the ratification of these
treaties which is producing the result
that I'm pointing to and again I think
it really has to do with the indigenous
ation the focal point in the sense that
what you're asking is legitimate because
your own government has told you it's
legitimate let me just answer the one
question that was destructed to me I
mean I it obviously is difficult to
measure you know public opinion or
public norms and I know that um you know
political science these days is clearly
skewed toward the measurable tour the
quantitative and you know other
approaches are sort of dismissed as just
anecdotal I think what I would urge and
there must be people who do this but I
just seen I'm not an immersed enough in
the field to know I would urge sort of a
more systematic anecdotal approach that
is to say I think the way to to kind of
get at these issues is to look at a
series of country situations and talk to
people who have been through the
evolution and ask them what their
analysis of what why things changed and
and to see if you can evolve a pattern
through kind of a serious sort of
systematic look at different additives I
mean just you know to pick one example
the bath cited here I'm not convinced by
the israel um statistics that because
you know i follow that situation and i
don't think the cat ratification have
much to do with anything because you
know there was already a legal
prohibition of torture you know Israel
it already ratified the Geneva
Conventions long ago which outlawed
torture I don't know when the ICCPR was
ratified in this mix but it also
outlawed torture you know cat was sort
of one more commitment by the Israeli
government not to torture but it was
redundant and and you know even when
there was a prior you know legal
commitment the Landau Commission had
come out and said moderate physical
pressure is okay and you know what was
the difference between the land up
Commission and the 1999 Israeli High
Court opinion that said no you can't use
physical pressures getting out of hand
you know the difference was a bunch of
fact-finding showing that you know what
was supposed to be rare occasional use
of moderate physical pressure in a
circumstance of a ticking time bomb
actually was being used all the time
because the security forces thought that
every Palestinian was a ticking time
bomb and if you know he may not know
where the bomb is going off that moment
but you know his friend might have a
cousin who would know where the bomb is
going off you know two months from now
and why are those victims any less
deserving of protection from torture
than the people who might be killed you
know with the bomb going off right now
and so it completely got a hand ninety
percent of the Palestinian security
suspects for being tortured and it got
to the point where finally the court had
to step in um I think that was much more
important than the ratification of cat
and I don't think you get at that with
the statistics you got to get at that by
sort of doing an anecdotal analysis talk
to people who were there who who
understood how the pressure builds
toward that court decision and and you
know I'm aware of the difficulty of
doing that and you know any single case
but if there was a way to do that more
systematically I'd be interested yes sir
rebuttal I just want to say there is one
aspect of the Israelis story that
neither one of us had mentioned that is
clearly related to the cat and that is
that once the cat was ratified it was
incumbent on the Israeli government to
report to the committee against torture
the committee against torture clearly
said now oh by the way those practices
you're engaging in those are torture
even though you've been saying you don't
do torture that was very very useful
information for these court cases that
information would not have been
available had Israel not ratified the
convention against torture and gotten
into this dialogue back and forth with
the committee against torture and it
becomes politically relevant to have
that information in your hand when
you're talking about that building of
though that litigation over time I just
want to say one more thing about the
public opinion there actually is a way I
deleted the slide because I just didn't
have time for it but I am have done a
little I did a survey on public opinion
in which I gave everybody a paragraph
that said that said basically said the
US has
has is engaging in practices that that
some people believe constitute torture
should we stop see if there is a there's
some some danger to the national
interest of the United States I gave the
same statement background information to
two groups altered only one bit of
information between the two and that was
the claim that the United States has
ratified the convention against torture
which prohibits those practices so you
there was a random treatment on public
opinion and the answers as to whether or
not the United States should stop those
practices are not shifted fifteen
percent in favor of the law treatment
the way that you would expect it so I
infer from that there are good reasons
to believe that people expect states to
to live up to their international legal
obligations and that potentially there
might even be audience costs domestic
audience costs for governments that
don't do so pointing we can get through
this through surveys and if these
surveys include a test treatment or a
law treatment suggesting there's an
obligation and a breach of an obligation
we can actually unpack precisely the
difference between public opinion and
treaty ratification yes Exxon November
11th in the series we will talk about
the politics of corruption rankings and
indices of them lata boo Kavinsky from
Smith College will have nay teller who's
the head of global integrity and Herman
Institute Director 10 director Tim fry
so mark that in your calendars November
thank you